[Musik]
breaking news
ja und folge breaking news hat uns
erreicht und sie ist eine richtige
klatsche für kanzler olaf scholz im
corona chaos die impfpflicht ab 18 ist
gescheitert julius bär ist dazu bei uns
im studio hallo schön dass du zeit
gefunden hast war doch klar oder es
könnte man jetzt so aus der
retrospektive sagen aber das ist klar
war aber bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat
im dezember gesagt er unterstützt die
impfpflicht karl lauterbach trommelt und
kämpft seit monaten für eine impfpflicht
ab 18 jahren und hier ist das papier der
sogenannten gruppe im pflicht ab 18 die
am wochenende getagt hat und gefeilscht
und verhandelt hat und gesagt hat wie
können wir ein kompromiss schaffen dass
wir trotzdem noch eine mehrheit im
bundestag bekommen können am donnerstag
und hier steht es jetzt schwarz auf weiß
die endlich 18 kommt nicht erst mal laut
diesem vorschlag hier soll eine
impfpflicht nur für menschen ab 50 jahre
gelten die müssen ab dem sollen ab dem
ersten oktober dann geimpft sein müssen
verschiedene andere punkte wo man sieht
dass sie den anderen gruppen
entgegenkommen aber heißt unterm strich
es gibt niemanden mehr der die
werbetrommel rührte für die impfpflicht
18 es heißt in der begründung auch das
würde keinen sinn machen für diese
altersgruppe da hätte man jetzt auch
vorher drauf kommen können ich würde
behaupten nicht nur hierbei bild dann
auch weil viele medien haben das viele
experten häufig gesagt und wiederholt
wir wissen alle sei ziemlich beginn der
krise und mit unicom noch viel mehr dass
die menschen die vor kranken und älter
sind die gefährdeten sind und die
menschen die folgen können sich gut
selbst schützen wissen bescheid über
erkrankungen die menschen ab 60 jahre
während diejenigen die wirklich wurden
die wahrscheinlichkeit schwer zu
erkranken oder gar zu versterben steigt
und deswegen haben andere gruppen auch
diese infekt ab 50 in den blick genommen
weil dann so langsam die
wahrscheinlichkeit mehr wert aber
menschen mit 25 35 oder 45 jahren sind
eigentlich folgen der krise einigermaßen
wenig gefährdet was sind denn noch
gründe für das aus jetzt der impfpflicht
spielt vielleicht auch der krieg eine
rolle dass man sagt der fokus liegt
jetzt woanders man kümmert sich nicht
mehr so um das thema ich meine wir
merken dass er alle selbst coruna spielt
hat nicht mehr so die große rolle in
diesen tagen ich dass er kriegt er eine
rolle spielt kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen aber corona spielt allen
voran nicht mehr so eine große rolle
weil die krise ihren schrecken verloren
hat wir sehen jeden tag neue zahlen
150.000 200.000 besser teufel wie viele
tausend und noch ein dunkelziffer die
das ganze verdoppelt und verdreifacht
und wir merken trotzdem hält unser
gründe system gegenstand es gibt zwar
200 bis 300 tote menschen am tag aber
das muss man ein sozusagen einberechnen
in jeden tag stellen in deutschland 1000
menschen man kann diese zahl nicht
einfach so lohse in den raum während man
muss das gut einordnen und da merkt man
bei dieser unfassbaren vielzahl an
menschen die gleichzeitig schwer
infiziert sind hat die krone krise an
schrecken verloren da kamen dann auch
dieses berühmte an oder mitbewohnern
gestorben da muss man denken
dankeschön